So the one other moment I want to show you
from this Trump propaganda press briefing
that he did over the weekend, that it is a
Bedminster golf club goes very simply to Donald
Trump's completely thin skin and his complete
inability to face any serious challenges to
his lies.
Now, if you watch the Jonathan Swane Axios
interview recently, you already know that
Donald Trump completely implodes when subjected
to even the most minor fact checking.
But in the interview with Jonathan Swann,
he wasn't really able to do what he did when
CBS is Paula Reid confronted him.
Now, as I told you in the last segment.
Donald Trump has been regularly taking credit
for Barack Obama's policy veterans choice.
Obama signed it into law in 2014.
Trump regularly takes credit for it as if
it's something that he did.
Well, CBS News, as Paula Reid was not having
it and she called him out, and you will see
how Donald Trump reacted about being confronted
about such such an obvious and overt lie.
He does not take it well.
Take a look.
I mean, veterans.
John's choice, it was passed in 2010 excuse
me.
Go ahead.
It's a false statement, sir.
Thank you very much, everybody.
Thank you for.
So Trump just walks off abruptly.
This is how fragile authoritarian dictators
behave.
They pretend to be alpha and powerful.
And then when their wild claims are subjected
to scrutiny, they abort the situation.
Essentially now in some places, they'll also
have the journalists killed.
I don't expect that to happen to Paul Reid.
But Trump shrinks like a frightened turtle
and recedes into his shell.
This persona of big power and strength very
quickly falls apart when you confront him
and make him face his obvious lies.
And in this case, Donald Trump just walks
off.
Now, it also shouldn't be ignored that the
entire setup for this with the crowd of club
goers cheering Trump and booing the media,
it's scaling up yet another level, the degree
of sycophancy that's constructed around Donald
Trump all the time.
But I actually think that this is something
reporters should use to their advantage.
We've now seen Trump end press conferences
multiple times when a reporter is allowed
by other reporters to follow up.
And what Trump counts on is that when he's
done with reporter number one, even if they
try to follow up.
I was going to say, even if she tries to follow
up, usually this tends to happen with women.
He'll go to the next reporter and the next
reporter is often so desperate to ask their
question that they just immediately launch
in.
But when it doesn't happen, when a reporter
says, no, no, you can follow up.
It's often led to the end of a press briefing.
I remember this happened to CBS as Wadia Giang,
who was, I believe, Caitlin Collins from CNN,
allowed Wade Geia to follow up about something
related to China that Trump said to her, and
she's Chinese American and it didn't go well.
This happened to Caitlyn Collins when she
was allowed to follow up by another reporter.
And Trump tried to move on.
Ended up bailing on the press briefing.
And it's happened several times and again
this weekend.
And reporters should really make an implicit
agreement with themselves.
Let's allow each other to follow up even when
Donald Trump tries to call on the next person
and then he's going to end up bailing altogether
even more than he does when he is confronted
by facts, he frequently runs away.
And yet many of his 63 million supporters
from 2016 still see a strong alpha male there.
And seeing this actually makes me curious
about Trump's interest in debating.
He had to debate in 2016.
There was no way in 2016 as the challenger,
as the nonincumbent to say, I'm not going
to debate Hillary Clinton.
I don't think he could have gotten away with
it.
But right now, Donald Trump clearly does not
want counterpoints.
He doesn't want a scenario in which he could
be called out about his lies or fact check
to any degree.
My expectation is that if Donald Trump does
debate, his team will work very hard to keep
the rebuttals short and to put in place all
sorts of rules that will favor Trump, including
no fact checking by the moderators.
And if not, I would not be surprised to see
him find a reason out of the debates.
The most likely scenario is he will get what
he wants and the debates
will happen.